JEFF KEMBER: My
name is Jeff Kember.
We're going to be talking about
high performance file storage.
I've been at Google about
2 and 1/2 years now.
I'm a technical director for
media in the Office of the CTO.
So cloud storage it's a
really complicated thing
for some people.
When they come and
talk with us about it
they're like, wait there's
a couple different options.
How does all this work?
So Google has a ton of
compute, and they also
have a lot of storage.
And they try and keep it
really separated into just
two simple areas.
The Google Cloud
Storage that you'll
be running on when you run
a Google Cloud platform
is the same technology that
Google runs all the rest
of its infrastructure on.
I think that's kind
of the important thing
is that we don't have a
separate version for Enterprise
and a separate
version for Google.
We just have the one version
that is Google Scale.
So oftentimes we talk
about object store.
If you want to bring many,
many hundreds of petabytes
or exabytes to us,
object store is obviously
where you want to put it.
There's other
interesting use cases
though that take advantage
of our persistent disk,
and we have a hard drive variant
as well as an SSD variant.
You'll find it's called
just PD for short or PDSSD,
to make the distinction
for ultra low latency.
We also have local SSD.
So the distinction
here is persistent disk
is attached, sorry, it's
network attached I should say,
and striped and can
be up to 64 terabytes,
and expect that to grow.
Local SSD is up to
three terabytes,
and that's physically
attached to the machine.
In terms of our object
store, the cool thing
is we have a couple of
different flavors of it.
So multi-regional
allows you to be
able to store data
in two locations that
are more than 150 miles apart.
And that's compelling in the
fact that Google has a private
network-- we'll talk about
it a little bit later--
as well as we have dedicated
lines under the oceans
and between the data centers.
So multi-regional is really
fantastic for content serving.
Regional is
interesting in the fact
that, for the
highest performance,
the data is stored
in the data center
that you're performing
the compute operations on.
It's also slightly
more economical.
Nearline is our storage
for data that you
want to access sometime
in the next year.
And if the data's going to
sit as in an LTO replacement,
then coldline is the
appropriate option for that.
So the cool thing
with multi-regional
is the fact that it is
priced at the same price
point as our previous
version, except you
get the multi-regional aspect
included in that price.
So if you want to do content
serving and use either RC, CDN,
or use Akamai, or
use Fastly then
you're serving from
multiple locations.
So you're going to
be in a scenario
where your latency
is reduced further.
Simple API, these
are commands that
are going to allow you to
create a bucket, either
a nearline bucket or
a regional bucket,
and then you can read an
image from either of those.
It's the same API across
all of our storage,
and we're really
proud of the fact
that you don't have to be
using different systems to be
able to access it.
In terms of pricing,
as I mentioned,
it's really inexpensive to
use multi-regional as well
as regional in terms
of reads and writes.
We've priced it so that
you can almost make--
you're able to do
production level reads
with it without having
to pay additional fees.
You can see it's $0.04
per 10,000 operations.
So it's highly
performant, and you
can see that we have
11 nines of durability.
That level of durability
is consistent across
our entire storage offering.
So for regional, for many media
customers that I work with,
regional is sufficient if
they're not serving content.
It's optimal in
the fact that you
know you're committing a
right to that data center.
You don't have to
wait for two rights
to occur in two
different data centers,
it all just happens right
there within that zone
and within that region.
So it's highly performant,
and at the same time you only
pay for it as you use it.
So nearline was brought out
as our original LTO tape
replacement, and you
can even serve content
from nearline or coldline,
which is interesting in the fact
that it's the same couple
milliseconds at most, typically
less than that, access time
for any of these platforms.
With nearline, you can
work out the pricing such
that if you're going to read
the data in less than a year,
nearline makes sense.
We have a tool that
automatically ages the data
off, so that if you
wish to enable it,
you can take the
data from regional
and then move it to
nearline and then
move it to coldline
over time automatically.
From a performance
standpoint, we
came up with an SLA that was
several seconds of access time.
And this is in contrast
to previous offerings
that from other
vendors that may have
been several hours
in access time,
requiring a different API.
So the opportunity to have
nearline available to you
in a millisecond capacity we're
really excited about that.
And that enabled the opportunity
to have coldline available.
And for us, we
typically advise people
if you're not going to read
the data in a year put it
on coldline.
Both nearline and coldline
have a one month, a 30 day
requirement, in terms of cost.
Multi-regional and regional
are just as you use them.
Again, consistent
API, you can see
that we're using
the same GET/PUT
commands that you saw earlier.
And that comment about
serving the data,
performance wise
it'll do that, cost
wise we feel it's a better
option for you to be
able to move it to
another tier, which you
can do on a per object basis.
So this is a little bit
more of a breakdown here.
You can see on the
left hand side there
is no minimum storage duration.
On the right hand side, we
do do a 30 and then a 90 day.
So it's really intended
to be more for,
as you move toward the
right, more for longer term.
We have quite a
few customers who
are contractually obligated
to store three copies of data.
And in that context
they've now started
moving to storing two
copies of LTO tape
and one on Google Cloud.
And a number of them have now
gone to one copy of LTO tape
and cloud.
And they're finding
that they're not
restoring from tape
on prem, the tapes
are going off for
off-site storage.
And they're restoring
from Google Cloud
because they can get
it back in milliseconds
and only restore the
objects they need,
as opposed to restoring online
an entire LTO tape which takes
time and the robot and such.
So if you want to
use them all together
the cool part, as I
mentioned, you can do it--
we announced this when
we announced coldline,
but we didn't really
get a lot of fanfare,
the idea of having
the ability to have
multiple objects in a bucket
and being able to control which
category each object is in.
And that really helps from
a cost and performance
standpoint, because you're in
a scenario where you can say,
I have this 17 petabyte
archive and 50 terabytes
of it I'm going to be using.
So I'd like to have
that available to me
at a higher and easier
read cost, let's say.
And you put that in
a regional, and then
you can have another
portion of that available
in multi-regional, because
that's content that's finished,
final and you want to
serve that content.
This also mentions the data
lifecycle and the ability
to move easily between
in an automated fashion.
So when moving to
block storage, we
have persistent disk,
which I mentioned earlier.
So the machines boot,
when you fire up the VM,
you get persistent HDD so just
standard PD, and it performs
while it's our boot disk.
Quite a few customers use that.
It's inexpensive,
network attached.
The opportunity to move to
SSD for PD is also compelling.
We have a single
mode filer, which
I'll talk about in
the few minutes that's
backed by both local SSD,
essentially as RAM replacement,
in addition to on-board
RAM, but also it
has persistent SSD on it
for gain, high performance.
We're looking at 64
terabytes of gain,
but we can increase
that on the PD.
So local SSD, these are
three different use cases
that I brought up as examples.
So Avere is a on
premise, physical box,
and that's what people
are most used to .
They also have a cloud variant,
which just called the vFXT,
and it's quite a bit different
than the on premise box.
What's interesting about it
is it's the same algorithm,
but it's highly scalable.
It's your cash and your
file system together.
And the advantage of being
able to run that on the cloud
is you start with
three nodes and you
can scale up to 30 or 50.
You get the high throughput that
we have our machines, currently
16 gig per VM on a
40 gig interconnect,
and that's all software
defined networking.
So we're able to maintain that
line rate as you scale out.
With the vFXT, you can run it
on PD, SSD, as I mentioned,
or if you wish you can
run it on a local SSD.
When you run it on
local SSD you get
a couple cool things happening.
2X performance across
the board increase.
And for random reads, which for
many media customers or people
doing high computational loads,
it's a lot of random reads.
You get a 4 1/2 times
speed improvement,
because, there's no network I/O
required to go to the network
attached storage
to get your data.
It's just sitting there,
all ready, ready to go.
For transcoding,
I have customers
who will go use
FFmpeg, grab the data,
put it on a machine
with local SSD,
have the mezzanine file
there, do a transcode
to 27 different flavors of
codecs and resolutions and bit
rates, spit them all
out onto a local SSD,
and then copy it
over when it's done.
They don't even have to
set up a file system.
So that's, I think, a
highly useful use case.
It's also available
in small chunks,
375 up to three terabytes.
For simulation,
which Adrian is going
to chat about in a
couple of minutes here,
the simulation is
exciting in the fact
that you can do fluid,
just a fluid simulation.
You can do destruction work.
In the same simulation
idea, you can also
do finite element analysis
with car crashing simulation,
for instance, using our
GPUs, if you choose.
All of this can make
use of our local SSD
for ultra high speed
storage, and you
can supplement that with a
cloud file system as well.
This is a slightly
complicated and barely legible
graph it looks like
of hybrid rendering.
What we have on the left
hand side of the screen
is an on premises display,
and on the right hand side,
we have the cloud.
So really what we're
talking about here
is there's a file server,
there's asset management,
there's licensing.
There's all the
normal things you
would need to be able to make
a picture in this diagram.
On the right hand side, we have
the cloud equivalent of that.
So if you wish, you can
point back on prem across
and interconnect VPN however
you wish to configure with us.
Then you can point back
on prem to get access
to your asset management and
your cloud license server.
What's interesting
about this, for me, is
if you remove the
license server component,
and you change out the
compute VMs as being
standard compute VMs,
and change them for GPUs,
I would change the word
rendering to oil and gas.
Or if you decided
that you wanted
to run a very large
amount of compute,
like 100,000 course
for instance,
and you wanted to do
financial simulation work,
I would change the word
oil and gas to financial.
The framework looks the same.
It doesn't change.
We have genomics customers who
are using this same framework,
and they're able to complete
high performance compute
workloads on a permanent
basis on our platform.
So in terms of
customer use cases,
in an Enterprise
event we want to be
able to tell people, hey, look,
we have customers using this.
Here are the customers.
So we're excited
about the product,
and here are the customers
who are experiencing
great success with it.
Most of these customers
have come to us and said,
we don't want to be in
the business of having--
we don't want to run
data farms anymore.
We don't want to have to have
a huge amount of storage.
We wish to supplement the high
speed disks we have locally,
but the Tier 2, some customers
have an object store.
The customers who have
a large tape robot
they want to be in a
scenario where they
can start to move off of that.
As far as ecosystems
go, if you have
any of these products
on premises currently,
you're in a scenario where
these are all cloud enabled
to varying degrees.
These customers, sorry,
these partners I should say,
form our ecosystem
that allows you
to be able to extend your
current storage directly
onto Google Cloud in a
fully managed fashion.
And in terms of partners,
I mentioned Avere earlier.
We also partner with
PixCache out of the UK.
NetApp is listed on here.
These are, again,
fantastic opportunities
to be able to take
brands that you know,
love, and use currently,
and be able to just extend
the product that you have.
In terms of our
backbone, you can
see we have a whole lot
of lines on this graph.
The opportunity to expand
this, it's in 2018.
We're adding additional
under-sea links.
You'll notice there's
multiple links as well.
I meet customers who
are under the impression
from our marketing
information that we only
have kind of single
links under the oceans.
We have multiple
paths, and we're
the only cloud provider
on the planet that
has a private global network.
So in this depiction you
can jump on in Helsinki,
and then jump off in Taiwan, or
in New York, or back in Tokyo,
or Sydney.
And in that scenario, you're
on our private network
the entire time.
So it's all software
defined networking.
We have our own
quality of service.
We're in a scenario where it's
encrypted in motion and at rest
on our storage.
From a peering standpoint, we
have over 100 peering sites.
So if you're with
Equinix or other
there's a high likelihood that
you can run fiber directly
into our switch and have
a direct connect with us.
Talk with us about
those opportunities.
We have a roadmap, we're
offering new opportunities
in that area over time.
But the opportunity to be able
to be near one of our pops,
pretty much in most major
cities on the planet
where there's fiber
peering, we're
already in that [INAUDIBLE].
From a machine
learning standpoint,
this is an area that we're
really excited about in terms
of what can this do
for financial, media
customers, retail?
What's exciting for me
about machine learning
is the fact that it's prevalent
across our entire product line,
and Google has gone to the
trouble of building TPUs, which
are TensorFlow processing units.
So that gives us the ability
to run on custom hardware
at extremely high speeds.
That was the engine that
was powering the AlphaGo
competition that
Google won last year.
What this means to you,
though, is normally
you'd do your
training on CPU or GPU
and then you'd deploy
on that; however,
with TensorFlow units you can
get another order of magnitude,
typically faster processing.
And you can see we've
announced Cloud ML Engine.
We can talk more about
that in other sessions.
But you can see
we have an option
to go with open
source TensorFlow,
and you can run
that on any cloud
you wish, on your local
laptop or a data center.
You can take those
same graphs you've made
and also run them on Google.
So like our
container engine it's
a highly portable, open source,
machine learning technology.
The ML APIs are TensorFlow but
with our models already trained
and ready to run on them.
The cool part with that is
that you get our 100 languages
and translate, you get
our video and now vision,
I guess I should clarify,
vision and now video API.
We announced the
video API yesterday
as general availability.
And the exciting part
about that is it's
the Vision API on wheels.
So you can feed it
large movie clips,
it'll generate metadata for you,
and it'll do logo detection.
And it will allow you to do
optical character reading,
and it will tell you
where in the world
the scene is if it can
identify landmarks and such.
I urge people, if they
want to play with this,
to download Google Photos.
It's a free app for Android and
iOS, and the cool thing with it
is that it's a really nice
intro to how our machine
learning works for imagery.
You put it on your phone,
give it access to your photos,
it pushes them to the
cloud, performs the ML,
and then provides
that data back to you.
But you don't see
the outcome of it,
you just are able
to type in search.
You can type in dog and
you can get all the dogs
and your photographs.
But if you type in
Husky, Adrian's dog
will pop up on the
screen, as he has a husky.
So it's a nice way
to kind of go, well,
that's actually kind of cool.
That'll give you an opportunity
to see what the API can
do in an application setting.
The APIs are available
for anyone to use.
You can also, in
concert with that,
work with your custom model.
So in terms of that,
the normal process
is working with a
training workflow.
And then we've announced
today, this morning
I believe, data prep which
provides you the opportunity
to be able to simplify
the machine learning
training process for you.
As far as preparing your data
in a more accessible fashion
for you as a user to be
able to train your models.
And the prediction
flow is depicted below,
and that enables you to
be able to actually run
the model that you've trained.
So with that said, I'd like
to invite Adrian Graham up
on stage to talk with us
about simulation for media.
Thanks, man.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: Hey, everybody.
Everybody can hear me?
Good.
Oh, I've got a clicker,
forward and back.
So my name is Adrian Graham.
I'm a cloud Solutions Architect
out of the Venice office,
which is Venice, California,
not Venice, Italy.
The food is pretty good,
at the office still.
So my background is I come
from the visual effects world.
I spent 20 years working at
companies like Industrial Light
and Magic and Double
Negative in London,
and Digital Domain in
Venice, which is actually
where the Google office is now.
But one of my focuses, foci,
if you will, was on simulation.
And simulation is a good
practical application
for how we deal with storage
on any platform, local
or on cloud.
There's many challenges.
And if you think about what
a simulation artist who's
going to do a fluid dynamics
simulation for example,
they need a monster machine
with a ton of CPUs, maybe GPUs
if you've got GPU acceleration.
Massive amounts of RAM, because
once you generate the data
you want to read it back
in and hold it in memory
so that you could
scrub back and forth.
And obviously there's
a lot of disk required.
The data that you're generating
is on a per frame basis
and you're generating
data for things
that has fluid simulation,
like the liquid and the foam
and the spray and the mist.
And all those are on
a per frame basis,
and there could be thousands,
tens of thousands, millions,
or hundreds of
millions of elements.
So what do you do
with all this data?
How do you manage it?
And in that realm, we're only
talking about a production
problem, where you've
got multiple iterations
of the same effect.
And I'm going to use this
story from my old days
back at Digital Domain.
We worked in this production
on this commercial
for a video game
called The Darkness.
I can't speak to the
quality of the game,
but we had to create these very
sinewy, fluidy, smoky elements
that this character
could control.
And we use a tool
called Krakatoa.
Krakatoa is a way,
it's almost a pipeline
for generating simulation.
And the workflow is such that
you generate one simulation,
and then you run that simulation
hundreds or thousands of times,
each with a
different random seed
to generate slight,
slight variations.
And then you could take all
those sims as a single element,
and then you can combine
them and render them as one.
And that allows you to create
this long sinewy, smokey
effect.
Now that's just one
element, these shots
might have 8, 10, 20,
30 elements in them.
And they're written
on a per frame basis.
So when you think about
you needed thousands
of passes for each element,
each a shot might be 240 frames.
Remembering we don't
render to movie files,
we render on a per frame basis.
A 10 second shot is 240 frames.
So when you add all that up,
my example at the bottom here,
the end of the story is that
I got a visit from the Senior
System Admin telling
me that I was using
exactly 43% of all
storage at the facility,
and this is one
take of one effect.
So that is a huge problem, which
leads me to the next slide.
Because when we
only have one take,
what do we do if we want
to generate multiple takes?
What if the supervisor
says, that's great
but make it blow up
a little more here
or make it move a little faster.
And instead of just
running one simulation,
you want to run a whole bunch of
them, each with tiny variations
so that the supervisor can
look and say, I like that one
and I like that one.
Go in the middle of that.
A good example here is the
wedge of this fluid dynamics
simulation.
I'm only changing one
attribute, and that's
this max Voxel size,
which is essentially
the resolution of
the simulation.
But you could see tweaking one
tiny little value exponentially
changes the outcome, 25
million voxels from 226,000
from changing one value.
So what this means is what
if we could run all three
at the same time, and then
view them at the same time
and be able to choose?
And this is just one attribute,
you need to be able to--
these numbers are not
necessarily all normalized.
So you've got all
different attributes
that require all different
kinds of inputs and ideas
as to how to run them.
So put it on the cloud.
So let's talk about
how, real quick,
how I did that simulation.
That was a real quick
and dirty simulation
that you saw a
couple of slides ago.
I did it two days ago within a
couple of hours on the cloud.
But if we want to get a little
bit technical here, if I may,
we've got a couple scripts
that we're running.
We're running script
that runs inside of Maya.
We're using Maya bifrost, which
is a fluid dynamics simulation
engine inside of a product
called Maya by Autodesk.
It's got a proprietary
scripting format called
MEL, which is very sea-like.
Like
There's a tiny
little snippet here.
All it's doing is saying list
over all the fluid containers,
and for each container write out
the data that it's generating.
That, in turn, is controlled
by a Python script
which takes in-- that's your
UI, that's your front end.
And this is all command line,
we're not doing anything fancy.
And I'll show you what
the architectural diagram
for this looks like.
But essentially, it's taking
a start frame and an end frame
and a variable value and an
out-directory, and that's it.
So if we look at what the
command line, an example of two
wedging command lines
might be, in this case
we've got max Voxel size
or MVS of 0.05 and 0.001.
and I would run these
two separate commands
on two separate VMs.
So I can spin up a
managed instance group
with as many as I want.
And I could deploy
one sim to each group,
or sorry, one sim to
each VM in the group.
What do we do with
all this data?
Hope everybody gets the
Seinfeld reference there.
So once we've got
our chosen affect
and we've got the
magic numbers and we've
got an idea of exactly
where we want to go,
the output is going to
be the base simulation.
So we run it at full resolution
of whatever settings we want,
but we're not done,
we've got to mesh that.
And meshing is a
whole separate--
it's not a simulation
but it's a procedure
that runs on the simulation
data to surface it.
And from there we might want
to generate foam and mist
and spray and bubbles.
And those are all
separate simulations,
and all those simulations
generate data.
And how does it generate data?
It rams every CPU on
the box and spits out
massive, massive
amounts of data.
Which is ideal for
local SSD, for example,
up to three terabytes
in storage, what is it,
700,000 IOPS.
It will absorb that
data in the blink
of an eye with no problem,
and you won't get a visit
from your local system admin.
And then once you're done
with all the simulation,
you want to perform rendering.
And that is actually
the subject of a talk
that I gave a couple of hours
ago on rendering in the cloud
and running a remote
display over Teradici,
which I'll talk
about in a second.
So, quite simply, the set up
that I used to run all this
is extremely simple.
I just have one, I only
had one VM in the cloud,
but I'm using my local
workstation which
is just my Mac running Maya.
And I saved the file, I used
GSU to copy the files over,
and I just ran a shell
on the remote machine.
I actually have
a license server.
That's another problem, you've
got to deal with licenses.
But you need to
license the software.
So I'm running a license
server on the cloud
with feeding a license to
the remote display, or sorry,
to the remote machine as
well as to my own machine.
This is what Jeff
showed earlier.
It's a little more
legible, but it's
an extremely detailed layout
of how an entire visual effects
pipeline might be
built in the cloud.
If you want to see
more of this, or if you
want to talk about this, come
see us at the fridge texture
downstairs and we can
actually lay this out
and talk about it using
these little fridge magnets.
I hope everybody's seen it,
it's really a lot of fun.
Now, what I showed earlier
and I think it was recorded,
so you can watch it later, is
I did a remote desktop session
into the cloud.
So I didn't even have local
capabilities, I was using--
I was going over
Teradici PC over IP,
which is protocol
for remote desktop
by a company called Teradici.
And I'm running, in
this case, a Windows box
in the US central data center.
Which is about 1,800 miles away.
And the ping time was about
40 milliseconds round.
Pretty amazing what's going on
here because we were rendering
on 128 GPUs, 128 KAEs.
So, in all, thinking
about the powerhouse
that we have available
to us in the cloud
or how we could build a power
house, a 64 core machine,
nobody is going to
buy you one of those
if you work in visual effects.
But the fact that we can have
almost a half a terabyte of RAM
in the visual effects
world is unbelievable.
And at $0.80 an hour,
you can't beat that.
And you can of course
attach up to three terabytes
of local SSD, or PDSSD.
Compute GPUs, there's
also a number of renderers
that are running on the GPU.
There's Redshift and V-ray
RT and that type of stuff.
And the throughput
is pretty amazing,
up, to 16 gigabits per
second within a zone.
This demo, I urge you to go look
at it once it's posted online,
is that we've got
this massive seam that
is rendering on those 128
GPUs, and on my local Windows
remote instance, not
local, but remote instance.
I'm tumbling in almost real
time and it's resolving
in less than five seconds.
So, with that, we're going
to hand, the aluminum pole
over to Mike Warren.
Let me unlock it for you.
MIKE WARREN: Thanks Adrian.
I wanted to start with a
little bit about myself.
I have a PhD in
astrophysics, and my PhD
was simulating the universe,
the dark matter in the universe,
using initially a
million particles.
So over the span of my
graduate school career
to about three years
ago those simulations
with the same software went
from about a million particles
to a trillion particles.
So about a factor of
a million in scale,
and about that same factor
in computing performance.
And that came from Moore's
law combined with the scaling
in parallel machines.
And kind of in
the midst of that,
the popularity of parallel
machines got to the point
where we couldn't get time
on our local supercomputer
anymore.
So we started building
our own machines.
So you see me there on
the cover of Linux Journal
with a cluster of 16 PCs running
Intel processors connected
with ethernet, a very
normal architecture
these days but this
is 20 years ago.
So we've been working in this
same sort of environment that
would be completely familiar to
someone logging in the command
line of a Google Compute node.
And we've kind been living
in that world for the last 20
years or so.
So Descartes Labs was
founded just a little
over two years ago, some
scientists from Los Alamos.
We've doubled in size twice
now to almost 30 people.
We've now got an office here in
San Francisco and another one
in New York City.
And I want to talk about
today one of the problems
that we run into
at Descartes labs
and what we did to solve it.
And then at the end, I
want to do a demo of one
of our products that
we just released
earlier this week on Tuesday
which we call GeoVisual Search.
So one of the key reasons we
thought Descartes Labs was
a good fit as a startup,
is that satellites
produce a lot of data.
This is an imagery
made out of Landsat
8 data, kind of an
endless summer day
on the surface of the Earth.
The earth has never
looked like this,
it requires quite
a lot of processing
to get rid of all the clouds
and artifacts and other things.
But it makes a nice
picture to look at.
But you can't really
appreciate from this image
the fact that there's,
underneath this,
about 320 terabytes of data that
had to be processed in order
to make this image
that you can zoom
into any part of by
a factor of 1,000.
So I was going to use a quote
from Ken Batcher here about
I/O-bound problems, but the
lawyer said that would violate
copyright.
So I'm quoting myself
from a few years ago,
"A supercomputer is a device
for storing obsolete software
libraries."
And this is kind of to
point out the difference
between traditional
HPC and the cloud.
And you run something
on an HPC machine
those libraries just
stick around forever.
The Fortran matrix multiplies
that seem to never die
are going to be on every
one of those machines.
And at Descartes we started
fresh knowing that the cloud
was going to be the future.
And you can see that, today,
the fact that Intel came first
to Google with Skylake, not
the national laboratories
that had traditionally been
the leaders in supercomputing.
So what was the
problem we ran into?
And it's a core part
of the Unix philosophy
that everything is a file.
So the cloud does a lot of
things that are really helpful,
but one of the
things it doesn't do
is make architecting and
developing application software
easier.
So object storage, anything you
stick in GS:// does not conform
to the everything is a file
interface and it breaks a great
many things.
So the traditional POSIX
interface to a file is open,
read, seek, right, close.
You can't do any of those things
on an object in Google Storage.
You, instead, have a RESTful
interface through HTTP
doing GET and PUT.
And you don't have a file system
hierarchy with directories,
each object is labeled with
a globally unique identifier.
So one of the things
you can do with a file
is update a block
inside that file
without changing the rest of
the data, but in an object store
if you change one
bit in that object
rewrite the entire object.
Those constraints are
there for a reason,
it makes object storage much
more scalable and much less
expensive.
But the cost that
you do have to pay
is modifying code
that already exists
to work with an object store
rather than a file system.
So to give you an idea of
the relative importance
of these different
interfaces, we
used Google BigQuery with the
public GetHub repo database
and ran this sequel
query it to show
how often these various
interfaces show up
in the code on GetHub.
So f open showed up
about 740,000 times.
All of the rest of these
interfaces are less than 10%
of that.
So 90% of the code
out there is going
to be using a POSIX interface
and expect a file system.
So how do you match
these two API together?
Well, the typical approach
is you copy things
from object storage to a local
file using the persistent disks
that Jeff talked about.
So if you've got
relatively small files,
making a copy in the local
storage works pretty well.
You do a GSU held copy, it shows
up in your local file system,
and then your application
can read that data in.
And that second read
is actually very fast
because that data is coming from
memory, because the operating
system is clever and caches
all of that data in the buffer
cache.
But when we get to larger
files and higher data rates,
we're going to run
into some restrictions.
Because a PD hard
drive has a limit
of about 180
megabytes per second
of read bandwidth
and 120 megabytes
a second of write bandwidth.
The object store can actually
provide data much faster
than that, but you can't
ingest it and write it
to the disk at those rates.
Although, if you
paid attention today
Google announced with SSDs
you can now configure machines
with a PDSSD with something
like 800 megabytes
of read bandwidth on your node.
And what is often
the ideal situation,
if your files can fit
in less than about
half the memory of the machine
you just set up a RAM disk
and read the files from object
storage into that RAM disk.
It never runs into any of
these restrictions, and in fact
you then don't need
a local disk at all.
You can also try to
rewrite your code
and not deal with a
file system at all.
Go directly from the
object store into memory.
We like to do this with
Python where you can actually
do a GSU to a CAT on the
object through a pipe,
and then Python can
redirect that pipe
into a memory buffer
which you can pass off
to your application code.
But one of the
downsides of this is now
that data is in your
application memory
and it can't be shared
by other processes that
may be running on that machine.
And that's very much unlike
the file system, which
can share data to multiple
processes out of the buffer
cache.
And it's actually fairly hard
to write interfaces like that
because a lot of
application codes
are going to want a file
pointer or a file name
and you have to dig down
into the guts of the code
to actually find the memory
buffer that you want access to.
So, finally, object storage
just isn't an option
if you've got very large files,
hundreds of gigabytes which
are bigger than the
memory of the machine
that you need random access to.
There's nothing
you can do, apart
from the former solutions,
which are often, very
slow of reading to local disk.
So what you really
want to do is actually
put a virtual file system
on top of the object store.
And the Linux
operating system has
supported that for a long time
through the virtual file system
they call FUSE.
And here you can see the
first command in Festivus
was January 22, 2016.
So it's just a bit
over a year old.
But why did we write
this code ourselves?
Isn't this an important
enough problem
that there are lots of
open source solutions?
So we tried all the
solutions we could find.
There's gcsfuse, s3fs, a number
of others, but none of them
performed at the level
that we required.
And the reasons were they
were just slow at reading,
and they handled the
metadata very slowly
in terms of figuring out
what files were, what
their modification dates were.
So what is Festivus?
It uses the asynchronous API
of libfuse in the Linux kernel.
The kernel does callbacks
to this userspace code.
When you do a system call
like open in the kernel
it knows to talk
to the fuse module
calling the open stub
inside of that code
and doing the right thing
over HTTP to the object store.
and rather than talk to the
object store for metadata,
which is often
very slow, we just
put all of that in a separate
in memory key value store
so we can access that
with very low latency.
So a very important
optimization in all of this
is actually modifying
the Linux kernel.
Some of these
parameters in the kernel
have been set specifically
with disks in mind
where a block size
is four kilobytes
and latency is typically
below 10 milliseconds.
And now we're talking
over the network,
and we can read four megabytes
in about the same time
as it takes to read
four kilobytes.
So we want to increase
the kernel parameter
for the maximum number
of pages per request
from the default of 32, which
limits the size of the read
request you can make to the
object store of 128 kilobytes
to a much larger value.
So you can actually do
requests at 4 megabytes.
So since that requires
a kernel update,
we have to deploy all our
systems with a modified kernel.
And if you are
somewhere where you
don't have control
over the kernel,
you won't be able to do this.
If you're working in
Kubernetes and the kernel
hasn't been configured
with this parameter,
you can't access this
increased performance.
So how does it measure up?
So we can see the
first table we're
looking at the
bandwidth and gigabytes
per second on different node
types initially, and then
different numbers of nodes
reading in parallel to the file
system.
So the bottom line
there is 231 gigabytes
per second of I/O bandwidth.
Now that's an impressive number
even at a Supercomputer Center
where you've spent tens
of millions of dollars
on your Luster file system.
In fact, you've
spent so much money
on that file system you don't
let people store files there
persistently, it's
mostly a scratch disk
that has a fixed time.
But this bandwidth is going to
normal, multi-region, Google
Storage.
So it's reliable, it's
scalable, it's persistent.
So it's exactly what you want
for a high performance file
system.
The other table
shows the performance
versus gcsfuse, which is an open
source implementation, of what
sort of performance you
get if you're doing random
reads in a file, where you
can't depend on prefetching
to give you better performance.
So you can see that if you
typically read something
like 1 megabyte blocks,
Festivus is giving you
270 megabytes per second
versus gcsfuse is down more
than a factor of 20 from that.
And for very large
blocks we're basically
up at the network limit of the
node at almost 1,600 megabytes
a second.
So a question for you is
what's next for Festivus?
It does what we want it
to do at Descartes labs,
but is it useful
beyond our application?
And we're a startup,
we didn't intend
to write a file system
for other people to use.
We've got other things
that keep us very busy.
So what we have done, we
published a paper about this.
So if you're motivated
you ought to be
able to follow along
and implement something
similar for your own use case.
Could this be a viable
commercial product?
I don't know what the
market is for a fused file
system on top of object store.
Would we be better off
just open sourcing it
and letting the community
take over and take it
wherever they will?
And if you're not really
sensitive to performance,
you can use one of the other
open source implementations.
It does the same things,
just not as quickly.
So now for the
Festivus Miracles,
what does this file
system enable us to do?
And I'll go through a couple of
slides here kind of describing
the demo I'm going to show you.
But if you like you
can follow along.
These are publicly released
maps at maps.descarteslabs.com,
and our GeoVisual Search at
search.descarteslabs.com.
So first maps.
Now, everyone's used to
Google Map's earth layer
where you can scroll around and
zoom in and out on the world.
And we've done something
similar in the visual bands
with Landsat 8, which doesn't
go to as high resolution,
it is limited to 15
meters per pixel.
And this was collected from
about four years of data
from the Landsat 8 satellite.
But beyond the
normal visual bands,
there are some newer satellites
that collect information
in very different ways.
So in the middle there
you see Sentinel-1, which
uses synthetic aperture radar.
So it shoots down microwaves
at the Earth and measures
what gets reflected back.
So it can see through
clouds, and it
can detect things that are
very difficult to detect
in normal light.
Finally, Sentinel-2 is the
European Space Agency's
satellite, which also
has normal visual bands,
but in addition has a set
of bands that are just
beyond the visual into
the near infrared, which
are very sensitive
at classifying
different types of plants.
So that's in the region where
the chlorophyll or the cells
and the leaves of the plants
become very reflective
in a near-infrared.
So you're not just
limited to a normal map,
you can look across
all of these bands.
And this is just an example
of what the synthetic aperture
radar looks like in this area,
where the bright yellow shows
strong reflections,
often vertical buildings.
If you look carefully
a little bit
to the east of San
Francisco, there you
can see some spots in the
water and those are actually
where ships tend to anchor
themselves and have created
enough of a signal over the
average of all these images
that were put together to
show that pattern of where
the ships are anchored.
And then the demo
I'll show you now
is called GeoVisual Search,
where we divide Earth's surface
into billions of tiny images
and we extract a visual feature
vector.
And this was done
using Google Cloud,
using TensorFlow
on Google Cloud.
And once we have
those feature vectors
we then need a
way to search them
very quickly so that
when someone clicks
on a particular
type of object we
can search through all
these billion images
for the 1,000 images that
looked the most like that.
So if we can switch
over to the demo.
So this is our map
of the United States.
We can zoom in and out.
We've done some sort
of preset searches.
This was a waste
treatment plant,
which is just south of
Los Angeles airport.
And I'm not going
to use that one.
I'm going to go up
here and you can
see this is one of the
big parking lots near LAX.
So I'm going to click that.
And in that amount of time it's
found the 402 closest matches
across the United States,
and showing you up
on this map where they are.
And down here we see the
image chips from each of those
matches.
And you can see it's
done a very good job
in finding those parking lots.
So we can go up here and check
some of these other points
to see are they
really parking lots.
There's one, that
was a parking lot.
And go up here to North Dakota.
Turns out this is not
actually a parking lot,
but it's a junkyard of cars
parked next to each other.
So that's just pointing out
that it's GeoVisual Search,
it's things that look similar.
And you would need
other layers to go
beyond that for very
sophisticated searches.
We can do another one here
just of these wind turbines.
So there you can see
these kind of cluster
in the middle of the
country where it's windy.
But, again, we can go
and check our accuracy.
Here's some more wind turbines.
So if you'd like
to play with that
yourself just go to
search.decarteslabs.com.
Reserve yourself some time,
because it's fairly addictive.
So to wrap up, I wanted
to talk a little bit
about the Descartes
lab's platform.
So what we've done is taken data
from all the public satellites,
we're a partner with Planet.
Will Kirkpatrick is
going to be giving
part of the keynote
tomorrow morning.
Today, they
announced they'd move
seven petabytes of their
data into Google Cloud
and are now going
to be distributing
all of their imagery from GCP.
So our platform
is intended to get
rid of a lot of the
friction that people
deal with with these
massive satellite data sets.
So we have a very
simple Python API,
which allows you to
query and retrieve
raster imagery across
sensors spectral bands, time.
You can leverage the whole
ecosystem of cloud tools
on this imagery
however we would like.
We leverage the cloud to
be able to scale jobs up
to thousands of nodes.
This is a closed beta now.
If you're interested,
please contact us--
hello@descarteslabs.com.
Later this summer it
will become more open.
So finally if you'd
like to learn more
about the paper I mentioned
earlier, the link is there.
We have a technical
blog post on medium
describing GeoVisual
Search on our home page
descarteslabs.com.
We're hiring.
So if you love to work on
problems that are really
cutting edge and can help a
lot of people, let us know.
Thank you.
JEFF KEMBER: Really
want to thank Mike
for being here today,
fantastic presentation.
And Adrian, as well.
Excellent.
Thank you for coming.
We're going to have a few
minutes for questions.
There's microphones
in the center
as well as on the
other side of the room.
This is a great opportunity
to ask questions.
Please come up and let us
know what your thoughts are.